At last, the long arm of the law is reaching out and closing in on you, you screwy rabbit.
Trapped by his own tracks.
Come on out, you rabbit.
Come on, now.
You're under arrest.
My keys!
Where are my keys?
I just put them away.
Come on, hurry up!
Give me the keys!
What's up, doc?
Give me the keys.
Quick!
Get me out of this predicament.
Hurry up, unlock these cuffs.
All right, doc.
Keep your shirt on.
Take it easy.
He's an excitable type.
Now let's see now, there's the garage, the car, for the front door, and the back door...
Ah, here it is!
Oh well.
Oh no you don't.
You're under arrest.
On what charge?
You got nothing on me.
Oh no?
Well, listen to this.
Resisting an officer, assault and battery, trespassing, disturbing the peace,...
...miscellaneous misdemeanors, public nuisance, traffic violations,...
...going through a boulevard stop, jaywalking, triple parking, conduct unbecoming to a rabbit...
Nice-looking chapeau.
...violating traffic regulations.
Attention!
Why, look at you.
You call yourself a Mountie.
You're a disgrace to the regiment!
I'm gonna drop you out of the service!